i first of all want to thank the nhs for
the the the gps uh all the staff the
volunteers here at the centers like
these up and down the country they've
been working so hard if you think about
what they've done in the last uh
year or so
hundreds of
millions of vaccines have been
distributed um over 100 million vaccines
have been distributed and um the effort
has been incredible and i know that
people will be uh thinking you know have
we got to make another great surge like
we did earlier this year and i'm afraid
the answer to that is yes and i i just
want to say that we'll throw everything
at it and i hope that we can
do the same thing again because
everybody can see the situation we've
got a uh we've made a huge amount of
progress against the the delta version
of the of the virus of coronavirus uh we
now have this a question about the
omicron variant that has been located in
some parts of the world and now in the
uk as well
and while there's uh doubt about
what exactly that variant can do
what we do know is that the boosters can
give you a lot of protection against all
types of of the virus and we think
that's overwhelmingly likely at any rate
so the crucial thing is for everybody
now to come out and get your get your
boosters and that's what the the jcvi
and i was saying
and uh we've no doubt at all that the
nhs uh all the volunteers
the army uh everybody can can rise to
the to the challenge
is it is it going to be
hard work yes it is but i know that
people can do it
now people are understandably worried
whether or not they should modify their
behavior i just want you to talk a
little bit about what people should and
shouldn't do in the next few weeks yes
for instance should parents not expect
to see nativity plays face to face could
schools close early should people just
pause booking that foreign christmas
holiday okay sam we'll look just on all
that we're not changing the uh the
guidance on on how you should basically
be be living your life except in a
couple of of ways and that's to do with
putting a mask on in in some contexts
such as
retail and and public transport uh to
stop transmission and also making sure
that we check people when they arrive
into the country because what we're
trying to deal with here is the
potential threat from omicron and
what we need to do is delay the seeding
of omicron in this country that's why
tough checks at the the borders are so
important but we don't see any need
at present certainly uh to change the
overall uh guidance about how people
should be living their lives and provide
people
continue to be to be cautious and
sensible we think that's the right
approach because if you look at what's
happening with the overall state of the
of the pandemic the delta our strategy
for fighting the the delta version uh
the one that's been uh most uh dominant
for a while now uh has basically been
been working and there's no doubt at all
though cases are uh are high the numbers
of people being admitted to hospital
numbers people being admitted to icu
and and a sadly number of people dying
uh that those numbers have all been
coming down so it continues to go in the
right direction what we need to do is to
take special measures now to protect
against the arrival of omicron to delay
until we've established exactly what
we're dealing with and so we need the
scientists at port and down we need the
the scientists in the in the in the
vaccine companies
to work out exactly uh to what extent
this
new variant omicron may escape uh the
vaccines and and that means and there
are ways in which can it can sit it can
either be more transmissible uh or else
of course it can cause more serious
illness and death and
i just want to stress
whatever the risks the answer is
everywhere and always to get the booster
because we think that it's
overwhelmingly likely that the booster
getting vaccinated vaccinated will give
you more protection if that's the case
and only small changes are being
requested by you what do you think jenny
harris your advisor said this morning uh
that people think should think about in
her words not socializing when you don't
particularly need to over the winter
months why do you disagree with that i
look i think it's always sensible to uh
be be careful and i think what jenny is
saying there is right you know we've
been living with a pandemic for a long
time people should continue to do things
like uh
make sure they
have lots of fresh air they'll wash
their hands and and take normal
precautions i think that's entirely
reasonable but we're not going to
change the the overall
guidance we don't think that's necessary
we don't see anything to suggest that we
need to go for instance to to plan b
but what we do need to do is take
particular precautions against omicron
until we've worked out exactly what kind
of a threat it may present but whatever
kind of a threat it may present sam the
crucial thing to do is for everybody to
go out and get vaccinated and yes it's
going to be a a big campaign and it will
it will absorb a huge amount of effort
but i i've no doubt that the nhs the
volunteers and everybody else can do it
um the boss of moderna said today that
his vaccine would be much less effective
because of the new variant and it would
be months before we get a new one
do you think that's right i think i
think what stephan bolsell was was
saying uh is is is probably right but
you need to you need to look at uh what
he's what he's what is he not
necessarily saying that uh this will
mean that the vaccines are uh
ineffective against serious illness or
or death and uh they may be uh less
effective in preventing transmission we
see we see some evidence from south
africa that it's uh it's the virus
omicron is is transmitted between uh
people who have been vaccinated but it's
it's not clear uh to what extent uh
this means that uh you're gonna get
you're gonna pick up a severe uh case of
of omicron or that will have a problem
with uh serious illness and death final
question prime minister you're telling
the nation to get its boosters as far as
i can tell you're eligible why haven't
you had it i i am
and i've i've been waiting and waiting
but i'm proud to say that i'll be going
along uh later this week and uh i'm sure
it will be duly recorded
by the by the way i mean i've been
waiting faithfully for my my my time to
come due but as you know jcvi
have uh have accelerated the the
timetable for everybody and and reduced
the the delay from your second jab to
your booster uh now to three months
which is great